um so
what is kind of like since you've been
doing the ig comedy thing like obviously
there's a lot of quote-unquote ig
comedians
there's a bunch yeah
what has been kind of like your
secret into like kind of standing out
and
i don't follow trends
i don't follow the trendy tick tock of
the day i'm not doing squid games this
week um
you know i technically go against the
grain on everything that happens you
know i mean if it's something that's
like i remember like i mean one of the
biggest kids i did was an r kelly skit
right you know
and that was around the time yeah that
was it was trendy but it just
you know
what you do a lot of people were making
like for example that skit i remember a
lot of people were playing gayle king's
part the interviewer
and i was like [ __ ] that man how funny
would it be to see the cameraman's point
of view
true
right so i ended up doing that and then
that [ __ ] got me like twenty thousand
followers overnight
so i played the cameraman point of view
because everybody else was playing the
gayle king like the interviewer like
they wanted to put themselves in the
moment right i was like nah that's just
that's already a scene as it is let that
happen
let me add the cameraman point of view
and then that's just it was off it was
out of here you know
um
but yeah it's just you know like i don't
you know social media comedy is really
like again man i i feel like it's comedy
is just like music subjective right
people like what they like yeah but i
just tend to go against the grain like i
don't like to follow the trends you know
and i like to be as original as possible
as original as possible you know what
i'm saying
um you know like even when i do my
characters like you know like when i did
it was so funny like recently somebody
was asking me like man how do you bridge
the gap between black and brown and
trying to you know the comedy and i was
like i'm not trying to bridge no gap
just doing you i'm just doing me you
know like when i did andre 3000
i wasn't thinking like i'm gonna do
andre 3000 because it's going to get me
closer to the back of me i was like no
that would just be a funny ass [ __ ]
andre thousand the mexican version like
that [ __ ] would be funny that should be
hilarious and dude and i had a bunch of
comments on my tick tock on instagram
like loving it you know and from the
black community they're like man see
here's a comedian that didn't have to do
blackface none of that to just be for
sure yeah and i think you know that to
me means a lot you know what i'm saying
like i'm not doing comedy for anybody
specific i'm just doing what i think is
funny to me and if you happen to be
white black or asian or mexican and you
like it cool